well maybe when I grew up in the
military very conservative Catholic
background and certain things are
considered received wisdom and not to be
questioned and of course that you know
can be very comforting for somebody it's
sort of scared me and I knew I was
different in terms of my sexuality quite
young and hadn't that sort of an
understanding that I'd probably deal
with that later at some point there was
an understanding that I wasn't really
ready to do that till the end of college
which is uh was a strange time to come
out because aids had just hit you know
and it was a complicated time and life
and death was involved and but also I
was very excited about entering the
world does it adult and sexual being and
someone who could actually be loved or
love someone because I wasn't really
into girls so I didn't really have that
outlet or opportunity to to feel those
things so I was like the first
generation of people who came out
understanding that safe sex was
important and people just a couple of
years older than me were dying so you
know even a year older and it was very
strange and I was an actor and at that
time in the early 80s he just didn't
really come out you know and it still is
very uncommon for actors to talk about
their sexuality lest they be
discriminated against and people think
oh well your case he can't play straight
though if you're straight and you play
gay that's generally a requirement for a
major award so I thought there was a
strange but you know intensity about it
it seems stupid to be scared and in the
closet you know thinking about being in
the closet when people were dying
and Reagan was doing so little and it
was a but again it was people who
weren't exactly my peers who were who
were dying so it was a very strange but
exciting time to be hitting your
adolescence at you know at that very
serious time and when you you know when
you're young you think you know stuff
and you don't and about relationships
certainly there's a cunt you know you
can read about how things just how
things go and that's our first way of
but you know or now in a more perhaps
more visual cinematic way you get you do
your research on what you're supposed to
you know what you're supposed to learn
about love about life about everything
and you you have these preformed of
opinions and especially now and in this
information age there's a kind of false
false wisdom or pre-digested kind of
well what do you think you know and it's
like your comment on the you know post a
comment and we'll North Korea attack you
vote you know and it's like the sort of
false kind of like knowledge that people
foist on you and you're supposed to have
it you know you're on Facebook and
you're supposed to know you're or your
sexual orientation at that thirteen is
like I don't nobody really knows what's
going on at that time and it people seem
to you know seem to know stuff or they
have to act like they do and they make a
decisions before they really need to and
it's a strange - strange thing so I did
that a bit too and then you know the
older you get realized the less you know
and you know some things and I guess the
key thing is to don't make a decision on
bit on based on some fear of the unknown
I mean I make decisions based on fear of
the known all the time I mean
what the voting booth is hopefully for
but if it's something based on fear of
the unknown it's probably a bad decision
that's the only thing I know